so a sort of novelty from last week was
Donald Trump's son-in-law showing up to
a White House coronavirus press briefing
with Donald Trump and Jared Kushner is
Donald Trump's slumlords son-in-law
married to Ivanka Trump son of convicted
felon Charles Kushner and Jared Kushner
thinks he can manage his way to success
no matter what the challenge he was put
in charge of solving the
israeli-palestinian conflict for Donald
Trump you probably have some idea of how
well that's going so far so Kushner
shows up at a press conference last week
and his presence is completely sinister
in nature I actually posted a poll on my
Twitter page asking who disturbs you
more by being at the White House press
briefings and by just a massive margin
about 18,000 people voted it was Kushner
by a longshot
78 to 22 Kushner more disturbing than
the my pillow guy and I have to say I
totally agree the my pillow guy was a
religious nut Trump supporting
brown-noser but he's at least just
trying to make some masks for health
care workers Jared Kushner is
involvement in the coronavirus response
is actually downright ominous so let's
look at one clip from Kushner we'll look
at another clip in a second segment
Jared was asked about all of the state
governors who have been asking for
ventilators they've been asking for
masks and other supplies and not all of
them have been getting them and Jared
Kushner pulls some sort of total
management consulting mumbo-jumbo about
how the federal stockpile is our
stockpile not for the states and of
course the question is who is us like
when he says the federal stock file is
for us who are the people that he's
referring to take a look at this
completely unintelligible sinister
depraved clip and if in instances where
in cities they're running out but the
state still has a stockpile and the
notion of the federal stockpile was it
supposed to be our stockpile it's not
supposed to be state stockpiles that
they then use so we're encouraging the
states to make sure that they're
assessing the needs they're getting the
data from their local
local situations and then trying to fill
it with the supplies that we've given
them the same thing with the masks the
notion of the federal stockpile was it's
supposed to be our stockpile not the
state stockpiles that they then use so
of course it's supposed to be our
stockpile is our and us being who
doesn't everyone live in one of the
states like is he saying the stockpile
is only for people who live in DC Puerto
Rico Guam like what what does it mean
that it's for us and not for the states
who is the stockpile for it's a sinister
ominous Orwellian explanation and you
know how you can tell that Jared messed
up here because the next day Donald
Trump was asked about it
and when he was asked about it he told
the reporter that they should be ashamed
of themselves when Donald Trump tells a
reporter you should be ashamed of
yourself it means it's a good question
it means Trump's up against the wall and
it means Trump is trying to defend the
indefensible check this out from the day
after yesterday Jared Kushner said the
notion of the federal stockpile was it
supposed to be our stockpile it's not
supposed to be state stockpiles that
they then use what did he mean by our
our you know what our means United
States of America that's what it means
it means our our it means the United
States of America and then we take that
our and we distribute it to the states
not either not supposed to be state
stockpiles that they because we need it
for the government and we need it for
the federal government but when the
states are insured no to also keep state
to keep to keep for our country because
the federal government needs a to not
just the states but out of that we
oftentimes choose as an example we have
almost 10,000 ventilators and we are
ready to rock with those ventilators
we're going to bring them to various
areas of the country that need them but
when he says our he's talking about our
country he's talking excuse me he's
talking about the federal government I
mean it's such a basic simple question
and you try and make it sound so bad you
got to be you ought to be ashamed of
yourself you know what you to Bishop
it's such a simple question how shameful
for a reporter to ask about a completely
incoherent statement from someone Jared
Kushner who has no business whatsoever
managing the response to a virus
pandemic Trump is doing the same thing
by the way ours means the u.s. stockpile
not the state stockpile so we give the
stockpile to States which Jared said we
aren't doing because we need the
stockpile for the federal government
what the stockpile is to treat federal
government employees like what on earth
is it that they are arguing here and
then now we get to the really Orwellian
twist right after Jared Kushner said
this last week it's our stockpile not
the state's the national stockpile
website was changed before Jared
Kushner's delusional comment the
stockpile website said the stockpile is
the nation's largest supply of
life-saving pharmaceuticals and medical
supplies for use isn't in an emergency
that causes local supplies to run out
when states request assistance the
stockpile ensures they get what they
need
that's what it said before Jared
Kushner's sinister Orwellian statement
after Kushner statement the website was
immediately changed and it now simply
says the stock pile is to supplement
state supplies many states have
stockpiles this can be a stopgap buffer
if states don't immediately have
everything available a much softer view
on the role of the stockpile for states
Jared Kushner ladies and gentlemen a
sinister Orwellian gerbil voiced lunatic
at these press briefings has no business
whatsoever being there and I actually
have one more Jared Kushner clip to talk
about here one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5 when
you sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cash back and lets you
create 36 credit cards a month and a $25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman